Oh
well I don't think it would make much
difference whether we call it a cultural
product or anything else of course to
some extent it's a cultural product I
mean the religions most people believe
in the ones that they they were born
with or part of the communities they
were born into and but recognizing that
is not going to lessen the hostilities
or the tensions that are there because I
think the reasons for those social
political and as I said earlier to do
with more general anxieties which are
not always very focused but when people
are frightened the first things that
they're going to react against
minorities alien minorities or a minor
is that look alien and the people who
supposedly have have power of the elites
who are blamed for making life difficult
it might do but the problem well it
depends on the political system in in a
basically two-party system like Britain
Britain or all the United States for
that matter and having a splinter party
that's religious that kind doesn't make
any difference in countries with
proportional representation where your
coalition governments in many parties
there are of course religious parties
you have Christian Democrats you have
Christian parties of various kinds and
it's very possible that there will be
Islamic parties of that nature the the
problem with forming an Islamic party
and there have been people who've tried
is that there is no such thing as an
Islamic community they're very divided
they come from very different cultures
there there is a schism between the
Shiites and the Sunnis and so on so it's
difficult for Muslims to make a common
political cause even though from the
outside from the non-muslim perspective
they all may look like quite one great
monolith
well yes because without compromise you
can't have a liberal system liberal
democratic system that's the name of the
game and so you'd have to have
compromises and in fact on a daily basis
we have compromises that the question is
where do you draw a line and with other
things that you cannot compromise with
and I would draw the line always at the
use of violence or the threat of the use
of violence if people use violence or
threaten violence to impose their views
on others that's something that cannot
be tolerated or compromised with